欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课 第二小题我们来讲一下 如何拔高自己的运营能力 让自己更加值钱
因为我看了很多运营可能做了一到两年 或者是三年 他的薪资涨幅比较低 甚至是基本没什么变化
这个很有可能就是跟你所在的地区有关 第二个就是最关键的就是可能你本身的技能就没有那么强
达不到结果 所以说你的价值就得不到体现 创造不了价值
那么企业就是不可能给你增加薪资的 或者是给你更高的岗位的
所以我们一定要懂得去拔高自己的运营能力 让自己更加值钱
那么我们要怎样去拔高自己的运营能力呢 提升N个档次呢 第一个 我们一定要去重视
运营基础知识 这是你最底层的核心理论概念 去帮助你搭建所有的
方法的迁移和应用的一个基石 如果你没有这些知识 那么你是很难去把这些知识变成技能的
所以一定要重视基础知识 绝大部分的运营 无论他做了多久 很多人都小看了这部分的简单的知识 其实简单的往往是最有效的
但是呢 却被很多人忽视 所以在这里就重点强调一下 这个非常非常的关键
第二个就是实战应用能力 也就是很多人眼高手低 觉得好像自己看了都懂 但是呢 他就是不去操作 他就是不去应用
所以说他就很难拿到结果 只要你学到的东西不去应用 就一定很难拿到结果 所以说你学到了一招
那你就要去把这一招应用到极致 让这一招能够为你带来实实在在的结果 而不是追求一千一万种招数
但是呢 一个招式都没有给你带来任何的结果 那么这就是在浪费时间 浪费个人的精力
所以一定要去应用 学 学会了就要马上去用起来 这样才能够更加快速的把这些知识
变成你的技能 第三个呢 就是成功案例的打造 很多人做一个店铺 他就是平平淡淡的 没有任何的一点流量的波动
比如说他都是这样平平淡淡的 所以说别人都看不到他的价值 就觉得好像有你的存在和没你的存在差不多
所以在做店铺的时候 你一定要按照这种线去做 在某一个临界点实现突破 或者是在某一个节点
你的运营思维 或者是你的方法 能够有一定的突破 这样才能够让别人看得见你 才能知道你更加的值钱
不然的话 你都是这样平平淡淡 有你跟没你差不多 那为什么会给你加工资 或者是说给你提升岗位呢 是吧
所以你在做店铺的时候 一定要去学会打造一些案例 比如说你报品 报增多少 或者是寻盘
报增了多少 或者是说你的店铺从行业均值 用同样的预算 达到了TOPO 或者是说跟同行优秀接近 那么这种都是你的一些成功案例 那么你就会把这些案例成功的方法总结出来 形成你自己的实战方法就可以了 那么这些需要多长时间就能够实现呢 运营基础支持可能需要三个月 实战技能可能也
也就是要三个月 成功案例打造可能要长一点 六个月 那么整体来说可能就是一年就能够达成这些目标 当然这个也会因人而异 因为有些人的理解能力强一点 而且他愿意去学 愿意花更多的时间 那么他的时间可能就会更广一点 可能八个月 如果你理解能力没那么强 可能就需要更长一点的时间 但是你可以更加勤奋 用时间去弥补就可以了 你的方法和方向
一定是在大致正确的前提下 才能够更加有效 这节课就是教大家如何拔高自己的运营能力 让自己更加值钱 希望你重视起来 因为这个和你的职场非常的相关
很多跟我学习的运营 如果按照这三个步骤去做 那么基本能够在一年内实现加薪 这是非常正常的 因为很多小白开始的薪资比较低
那么他通过学习完之后 他可能掌心翻倍 不有可能 这些没有什么奇怪的
所以说一定要重视起来 开始去行动 这节课我们就先讲到这里 下节课我们再见